한국 화장품이 요즘 해외에서 정말 많이 팔리고 있죠.
예전에는 K-뷰티라고 하면 중국 시장을 먼저 떠올렸습니다.
그런데 지금은 분위기가 많이 달라졌습니다.
미국, 일본, 유럽, 중동, 동남아까지 시장이 넓어지고 있습니다.
여러 제품들이 해외 소비자들에게 계속 팔리고 있고
한국 화장품 수출도 다시 기록을 쓰고 있죠.
이 흐름 속에서 최근 가장 눈에 띄는 회사 중 하나가 있습니다.
바로 한국 콜마입니다.
한국 콜마는 2016년 1분기 연결기준 매출 7,280억 원,
영업이익 789억 원을 기록했습니다.
전년동기 대비 매출은 11.5%, 영업이익은 31.6% 늘었습니다.
매출과 영업이익 모두 분기 기준 역대 최대 실적이었습니다.
2015년 전체 실적도 좋았습니다.
연결기준 매출은 2조 7,224억 원, 영업이익은 2,396억 원이었습니다.
그리고 2016년에는 공정거래위원회가 지정하는
공시대상 기업진단, 쉽게 말해서
자산 5조 원 이상 대기업진단에도 새로 이름을 올렸습니다.
그런데 여기서 한 가지 질문이 생깁니다.
한국 콜마라는 이름, 소비자에게 아주 익숙한 브랜드일까요?
우리가 화장품을 살 때는 보통 브랜드를 봅니다.
아모레퍼시픽인지, LG생활건강인지,
올리브영에서 잘 팔리는 인디브랜드인지,
아니면 SNS에서 유명해진 제품인지를 확인합니다.
하지만 한국 콜마라는 이름을 보고
직접 화장품을 사는 소비자는 많지 않습니다.
이 지점이 한국 콜마를 이해하는 핵심입니다.
한국 콜마는 소비자에게 직접 화장품을 파는 브랜드 회사라기보다
브랜드들이 팔 제품을 개발하고 생산해주는 회사에 가깝습니다.
그러니까 한국 콜마의 성장은 단순히
어떤 화장품 브랜드가 잘 팔렸다는 이야기가 아닙니다.
K-뷰티 브랜드들이 빠르게 제품을 만들고
해외 시장에 맞춰 확장할 수 있도록
제조와 연구개발 기반을 만들어 온 회사의 이야기입니다.
이 이야기는 1990년
아주 작은 공간에서 시작됩니다.
창업자는 윤동한 회장입니다.
그는 16년 동안 다니던 안정적인 직장을 그만두고
창업을 선택했습니다.
당시 나이는 43세, 두 아이의 아버지였고
대기업 생활을 이어갈 수도 있었습니다.
하지만 그는 화장품 제조 시장에서 기회를 받습니다.
처음 시작한 곳은 충남 영기군, 지금의 세종시 일대였습니다.
시골의 작은 오평 창고에서 사무실을 만들었고
직원은 고작 몇 명 수준이었죠.
설립 초기에는
전기세를 밀릴 정도로 사정이 어려웠다고 알려져 있습니다.
그런데 윤동한 회장이 이 시장을 포기하지 않은 이유가 있습니다.
그는 1990년대 한국 화장품 시장이 바뀌고 있다는 걸 봤습니다.
당시 한국 화장품 시장은 방문판매 중심에서
종합 화장품 매장 중심으로 이동하고 있었습니다.
한 브랜드 제품을 방문판매로 사던 방식에서
여러 브랜드 제품을 비교하고 구매하는 구조로 바뀌기 시작했던 겁니다.
브랜드가 늘고 수입 화장품까지 들어오면서
시장은 빠르게 달라졌습니다.
여기서 중요한 변화가 하나 있었습니다.
브랜드는 많아지는데
모든 브랜드가 직접 연구소를 만들고
공장을 짓기는 어렵다는 점이었습니다.
화장품 하나를 만들려면 아이디어만 있으면 되는 것이 아닙니다.
원료를 고르고, 제형을 잡고, 사용감과 품질을 맞추고
대량 생산과 납기까지 관리를 해야 하죠.
작은 브랜드가 이 모든 과정을 직접 감당하기는 쉽지 않습니다.
윤동한 회장은 바로 이 지점을 봤습니다.
앞으로 화장품 브랜드는 늘어날 것이다.
그래서 그 브랜드들을 대체하고,
대신에 제품을 개발하고 생산해주는 회사가 필요해질 것이다.
이 판단이 한국콜마의 출발점이었습니다.
여기서 한국콜마의 핵심 모델이 등장합니다.
ODM입니다.
OEM은 주문 받은 제품을 만들어주는 방식에 가깝습니다.
브랜드가 설계하고, 제조사는 그 설계에 맞춰서 생산하는 구조입니다.
반면 ODM은 제조사가 제품 개발 단계부터 참여합니다.
어떤 원료를 쓸지, 어떤 제형으로 만들지, 어떤 사용감을 줄지,
어떻게 생산할지까지 함께 설계하는 거죠.
즉, 브랜드가 이런 제품을 만들고 싶다고 하면,
ODM 회사는 그 아이디어를 실제 제품으로 바꿔주는 역할을 합니다.
한국콜마는 이 ODM 모델을 한국 화장품 산업에 본격적으로 들여온 회사로 평가받습니다.
이게 왜 중요하냐면, K-뷰티의 성장 방식과 맞아떨어졌기 때문입니다.
K-뷰티는 대형 브랜드만으로 성장한 산업이 아닙니다.
수많은 중소브랜드와 인디브랜드들이 등장했고,
트렌드에 맞는 제품을 빠르게 출시했습니다.
브랜드가,
혼자서 연구개발과 생산을 모두 담당했다면,
그렇게 빠르게 움직이기 어려웠을 겁니다.
한국콜마 같은 ODM 회사가 있었기 때문에,
브랜드들은 제품 기획과 마케팅에 집중할 수 있었고,
개발과 생산은 전문 제조사가 맡을 수 있었습니다.
이 구조가 K-뷰티의 속도를 만들어냈습니다.
한국콜마의 성장은 단순히 공장을 잘 운영한 결과만은 아닙니다.
이 회사가 꾸준히 강조한 것은 연구개발이었습니다.
2000년에는 중앙연구소를 열었습니다.
이후 생명과학연구소, 종합기술원 등 연구개발 조직을 계속 키워왔습니다.
한국콜마는 매출의 5% 안팎을 연구개발에 투자해온 것으로 알려져 있습니다.
화장품 제조사는 단순히 제품을 찍어내는 곳이 아닙니다.
ODM 회사는 고객사가 원하는 제품을 실제로 구현해야 합니다.
발림성, 흡수감, 지속력, 안정성, 원료배합, 규제 대응까지 모두 맞춰야 합니다.
그래서 한국콜마에게 연구개발은 선택이 아니라 핵심 경쟁 얘기였습니다.
하지만 기술만으로는 부족했습니다.
고객사와의 신뢰도 중요했습니다.
화장품은 겉으로 보면 비슷해 보여도
실제로는 제품마다 원료배합, 제형, 향, 사용감, 생산 방식이 모두 다릅니다.
브랜드 입장에서는 이런 제품 개발 내용 자체가 경쟁력입니다.
ODM 회사는 이 정보를 함께 다룹니다.
그렇기 때문에 고객사 입장에서는 한 가지 걱정이 생길 수밖에 없습니다.
내가 맡긴 제품 개발 내용이 다른 회사 제품에도 그대로 쓰이면 어떡하지?
한국콜마는 이런 불안감을 줄이기 위해
고객사별로 제품 개발 내용을 구분하고
같은 개발 방식을 여러 회사에게 돌려쓰지 않는 원칙을 강조해 왔습니다.
결국 한국콜마가 쌓아온 것은 생산 능력만이 아니었습니다.
제품을 구현하는 기술, 품질을 지키는 시스템,
그리고 고객사가 믿고 맡길 수 있는 신뢰였습니다.
시간이 지나면서 이 시스템은 숫자로 드러납니다.
1996년 한국콜마 매출은 약 200억 원 수준이었습니다.
그런데 2025년 연결기준 매출은 2조 7224억 원까지 커졌습니다.
영업이익도 2,396억 원으로 사상 최대를 기록했습니다.
하지만 이 숫자를 한국콜마 혼자만의 성장으로만 보면 부족합니다.
이 회사의 성장은 K-뷰티 산업 전체의 변화와 맞물려 있습니다.
한국 화장품 수출은 최근 다시 강하게 늘었습니다.
2024년 화장품 수출은 100억 달러를 넘겼고
2025년에는 잠정 기준 114억 달러 수준으로 역대 최대치를 기록했습니다.
해외 소비자가 한국 선크림을 사고 마스크팩을 사고 스킨케어 제품을 삽니다.
그러면 당연히 브랜드가 먼저 보이겠죠.
하지만 그 뒤에는 더 현실적인 질문이 있습니다.
그 많은 제품을 누가 개발하고, 누가 생산하고, 누가 품질을 맞추고, 누가 납기를 지키느냐는 겁니다.
K-뷰티가 해외에서 잘 팔릴수록 이 질문은 더 중요해집니다.
한국콜마는 바로 그 뒤쪽에 있는 회사입니다.
그래서 한국콜마는 국내에만 머무르지 않았습니다.
중국에 진출했고 미국과 캐나다에도 생산 기반을 마련했습니다.
2025년에는 미국 제2공장을 본격 가동하면서 북미 생산 역량을 강화했습니다.
한국콜마의 또 다른 변화는 사업 영역의 확장입니다.
이 회사는 화장품 ODM에서 출발했지만 이후 제약과 건강기능식품으로 사업을 넓혔습니다.
2002년에는 의약품 위탁 생산 사업에 진출했고
2004년에는 한국원자력연구원과 함께 선바이오텍, 지금의 콜마 B&H로 이어지는 사업 기반을 만들었습니다.
2018년에는 CJ 헬스케어, 지금의 HK인호엔을 인수했습니다.
이 인수는 한국콜마가 화장품 제조사를 넘어
의약품과 건강기능식품까지 아우르는 뷰티 헬스케어 그룹으로 확장하는 계획이었습니다.
이 과정에서 2세 경영도 본격화됩니다.
창업자 윤동헌 회장이 한국 화장품 산업에 ODM 모델을 심었다면
윤상현 부회장 체제에서는 이 모델을 글로벌 시장과 헬스케어 영역으로 확장하는 흐름이 강해졌습니다.
특히 2022년에는 상징적인 일이 하나 있었죠.
한국콜마가 콜마 글로벌 상표권을 100% 인수한 겁니다.
처음에는 일본 콜마와 합작해 시작한 회사였으나
그런데 30년이 넘는 시간이 지난 뒤 한국콜마는 콜마라는 이름의 글로벌 권리를 확보하게 됩니다.
처음에는 기술과 이름을 배워서 시작한 회사가 시간이 지나면서
자체 기술과 글로벌 사업 기반을 갖춘 회사가 된 겁니다.
그렇다면 지금 한국콜마를 어떻게 봐야 할까요?
한국콜마는 소비자가 매장에서 직접 고르는 브랜드가 아닙니다.
하지만 K뷰티 제품이 기획되고 개발되고 생산되어 해외 시장까지 나가는 과정에서
중요한 역할을 해온 브랜드입니다.
한국 화장품의 성장은 단순히 마케팅이 잘 됐기 때문만은 아닙니다.
빠르게 변화는 유행에 맞춰 제품을 만들 수 있는 개발 역량,
일정한 품질로 대량 생산할 수 있는 제조 능력,
그리고 해외 규제와 시장 변화에 대응할 수 있는 시스템이 함께 있었기 때문에 가능했습니다.
한국콜마의 36년은 바로 그 과정을 보여줍니다.
처음에는 작은 창고에서 시작했습니다.
소비자에게 익숙한 브랜드도 없었습니다.
하지만 제품을 만들 기술과 신뢰를 쌓았고
그 위에서 수많은 K뷰티 브랜드들이 성장할 수 있었습니다.
그래서 한국콜마의 이야기는 한 기업의 성공담을 넘어
K뷰티가 어떻게 세계 시장으로 나갈 수 있었는지를 보여주는 사례입니다.
앞으로 K뷰티를 볼 때는 이런 질문도 함께 던져볼 필요가 있습니다.
어떤 브랜드가 잘 팔리고 있는가?
그리고 그 브랜드가 계속 좋은 제품을 만들 수 있도록 누가 뒤에서 받쳐주고 있는가?
한국콜마는 그 질문에 대한 대표적인 답 중 하나입니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.